those people go to jail over some
[ __ ] trout are they going to jail I
think so yeah wasn't it so crazy the
guy's just standing there can you bring
up that that fishing Lance Armstrong
skated on it and these fishermen are
going to jail those days I can seriously
Swamp People don't [ __ ] around
the French are like you learn your
lesson but they swamp people like nah
dude you gotta be punished two minute
cues of cheating in an Ohio fishing
tournament Scandal have been indicted
indicted as high level arrest is it well
apparently these guys actually like they
they like five different guys they took
away their like yearly income because
like this the amount that they want for
this is not a small amount yeah what do
you win what if you're the top level
[ __ ] let's guess what do you think
this tournament oh oh this tournament
alone I think top prize 28 000 oh that
might be too high
no I think I was gonna go 35 000. let's
see it's uh 29 000. damn
and I don't want to say the J word right
there
cut to the organizer I think yeah
Larry David Silver's got to get his cut
yeah oh my fish Burn yeah yeah
trout Bert trout
um uh this was a wasn't this crazy
though they put weights in it but they
they were just too it's like those guys
taking roids like take a little bit of
roids don't get the [ __ ] Barry Bonds
bionic head yeah you take too much just
put a little bit of weight in there put
a [ __ ] one gold coin in there
don't you don't want to pick up this I'm
like it feels [ __ ] like 80 pounds
what the [ __ ]
yeah every one of the fish it was crazy
because they'd have like a huge fish and
then a little fish and the little fish
was weighing the same guys
what the [ __ ] crazy yeah like
something's up like I don't know what
you're talking about apparently like a
bigger fish ate one of the little fish
and just sunk to the bottom of the uh of
the pond and they ripped these dudes
they ripped them apart and the one guy
stood there like he didn't know I would
have jetted yeah go go get on your
[ __ ] speed boat and go your lips go
live you know how to you you've taught a
man to fish you can do it you know not
as well as the other guys but you can
earn yourself a [ __ ] meal yeah yeah
oh I would have been out of there man
beats Amanda cheating fishing and I'll
fish it did God just pull I mean he
pulled a kettlebell I love that they
were like it's like a man got caught
cheating he was like wow that's crazy
fish must have been eating lead weights
yeah yeah
oh my God damn these fish must have been
hot
wow pieces of other fish you should have
just on that oh it's very Dom or ask
when you get to that part
he's just standing right there
wow refund all that [ __ ] so what did
he get it and then we got home with it
and they came back for another time
we'll go on Zach
I think they win money throughout the
season and so they're like this is just
now you got to give back everything
right it's like why Barry Bond's not in
the Hall
they're like we don't know when this
started oh it's true he was you could
see a guy being caught he's in the most
in midst of freezing
flight or fright or freeze you know and
he's just like he's just hoping it ends
he doesn't know what to do yes he should
get the [ __ ] out of there yeah you guys
should just run yeah no they'll chase
him down that now that's a good point if
he starts running he'd have been
probably a dead man yeah it's like if a
dog's barking if you start running that
dog is going to get you oh it's true huh
yeah yeah there's something about that
once you run it makes something else
want to chase you yeah don't let him run
yeah you have to be calm and calm them
around you yeah cheating and fishing we
found that money it's just it's part
it's sad it's just kind of the world we
in a lot of cheating out there you know
a lot of people just cutting Corners I
guess but I don't know everybody else
here seemed pretty pissed and seemed
like maybe maybe it's just these guys
sucks you're [ __ ] playing a game you
were cheating the whole time
so I was like what the [ __ ] come on
that's why I love the Tour de France
when they took it away from uh
Lenny Armstrong oh yeah and they're like
we gotta give it to the guy who came in
second place and they're like nah he was
roiding too and they're like [ __ ] third
like roid you know how far that 17.
uh-uh they had to give to the number 17
guy and I'm like he didn't even finish
the same day he [ __ ] finished on
Tuesday he all came in the [ __ ] you
know through the palace on Sunday like I
rolled up took a break stop for the
night he goes man I've lost I don't know
and then he's like tortoise in the hair
you know as long as you finish who knows
because he's not even a cycle it's just
a black guy in a chef's hat
he's an Uber Eats guy and he's like oh I
just came to the [ __ ] play Royale
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one